ni daniel grenier n'a pas une maladie
orpheline
mais trois qui attaque sa cornée ces
glandes surrénales et même le collagène
de tous ses muscles les problèmes
complexes qu'ils ont à peu près
immobilisé depuis deux ans avec le
syndrome d'ehlers-danlos par exemple
j'ai des dislocations fréquentent donc
mon corps a besoin d'en produire plus
dans ces circonstances là mais on
produit déjà pas du tout donc faut que
j'aille jusque là médication les
maladies orphelines handicap cinq cent
mille personnes au québec il y en a des
milliers
mais qui touche très peu de personnes à
la fois cela veut dire qu'il y à peu
traitement et peu de recherches pour
retrouver au moins 7000 d'identifier les
maladies rares puis au québec qu'au
canada on est à peu près les seuls au
monde dans les pays développés en ce cas
qui n'ont pas de stratégie que nous on
n'a aucune ressource manger au dessus
d'une douzaine de spécialistes qui
s'occupent chacun de leurs chaussures
chansons y en a qui se connaissent entre
eux au centre de recherche de l'hôpital
sainte justine
ils étaient nombreux à attendre une
telle stratégie lors de la journée
mondiale des maladies rares la
représentante du ministère de la santé
annonce et d'autres consultations mais
on est encore loin d'une stratégie
globale qui pourrait aider les patients
obtenir de meilleurs diagnostics et une
aide psychosociale ya vraiment un enjeu
d'accès d'abord aux soins façon quand
vous avez deux maladies rares vous
habitez loin de montréal l'accès aux
soins est tissée de l'autre grand défi
celui des thérapies et les traitements
deviennent de plus en plus cher les
trois quarts des maladies rares touchent
des enfants qu'au public ce qui serait
toujours contrer une diète sévère vient
vous connu qu'une force du cachot félix
lui cette impasse du nul est déficient
dans son système donc les gros
s'accumulent en son sein il ya aucun
traitement actuellement 90% des maladies
orphelines et rare n'ont aucun
traitement
si une chaîne marsolais radio canada
montréal